use the rotate tool to find the image of
pentagon cdefg that's this irregular
pentagon er over here when rotated 270
degrees about the point negative 2 comma
3 the direction of rotation by a
positive angle is counterclockwise so
it's counter counterclockwise
alright rotate tool to rotate around
negative 2 comma 3 so let's click on
rotate and then we want to go to the
point they say rotate around the point
negative 2 comma 3 so I move this to x
equals negative 2 y equals 3 that's what
we want to rotate around and we want to
rotate 270 degrees so it's this is maybe
the part that takes the most
visualization if we rotate 90 degrees
that would be going from you know if we
think about this arrow right actually
let me just do it so if I move this
arrow up here I have rotated 90 degrees
positive 90 degrees we're moving
counterclockwise now if I move it over
here we have rotated 180 degrees and now
I move it down here I have now rotated
it 270 degrees if they said 360 we would
get we would get back to where we
started
so this is 270 degrees it just like just
like that and we're done let's let's
check our answer and we got it right